[Applause]
[Music]
where you going I'm gonna get you
whenever she has a minute to spare
talita kv comes to play a little with
chiffon the male chimpanzee lives at
chim foon she wildlife orphanage a
sanctuary for animals in northern Zambia
Calvi as a vet was a former pet so he
was with some with the family for very
long of his life so he does enjoy human
interaction which is different than a
lot of our other chimps so that's why we
can get close to him and he actually has
the need of some kind of interaction
some kind of place because he doesn't
really know how to be a a chimp a chimp
chimp it's important to keep the chimps
healthy in the stations limited space
sick animals can quickly infect each
other let me see your mouth a mute
chiffon lives in a separate cage with
other chimps that have never learned
social behavior in a troop and are
therefore unable to integrate all of the
other chips at the station live almost
as they would in the wild they can move
about freely within a fenced in area the
size of about 200 football fields
chimpanzees are very social still if you
want to draw their attention you have to
have something to offer most of the 120
or so animals at the station otherwise
show little interest in humans the way
that we keep them as natural as possible
we face a few challenges so we used
opportunities like this as an enrichment
to bring them close to us so that we can
see them so that I can check them and
everything is voluntary so I don't I
don't push them to come
a little bribe doesn't hurt though chips
can always be tempted by a tasty snack
almost all of the animals at chim finchy
have experienced traumatic events in
their lives many were ripped from their
families at a tender age because chimps
defend their young that often entailed
the slaughter of almost an entire band
the forests of chim finchy provide
almost enough forage to meet the animals
needs but not quite so twice a day staff
here also prepares supplementary food
for the chimps it's served at their very
own chimp restaurant the animals are
already waiting impatiently for the meal
to begin venison Mulenga heads the
station he's an expert on Apes
he's been around some of the chimps
since he was a child
and knows how to handle them
[Music]
we feed them in such a huge house
because we want to separate the males
from the females and the young ones
because the males are dominant and they
always want to eat everything so this is
why we separate them it's unlikely any
of the chimps here will ever join a
troop again out in the bush in the wild
their range grows more restricted year
by year most of the chimpanzees that you
fishing come from more Congo which is
like 18 kilometers from here
but in Congo these lawlessness there
there was there I'm so this difference
is the affront to poachers and people
that doing push me trade in the last few
years the wildlife refuge has grown
steadily there's now a school for the
children of the sanctuaries employees on
the grounds of the station malanga says
this school has made a big difference
for the people who work here
we've got our Kezia that work for the
chimps and really there is no school
anywhere near so in 2007 we bought this
core so that their children can have a
decent education
Chifa she is most just about chimpanzees
but also about the humans and this is
why this project is looking at helping
the children get required education most
of the funding comes from a German
businessman whose brother helped set up
the project 30 years ago after his death
his family wanted to keep chimp Vinci
going and recently bought a nearby farm
it's meant to give the project
longer-term perspectives and help it
provides some of its own funding on its
grounds fruit and crops are harvested to
help feed the chimps while cattle are
raised to provide income the first will
soon be sold at market more work for
veterinarian Teddy tech-heavy who takes
care of all of the animals at chin foon
Shane out in the chimps forest enclosure
feeding time is over things are peaceful
on the grounds of the refuge but to get
here it's taken a lot of hard work and
plenty of willing hands
the idea really is for this gypsy to
have a good home this is why we have put
all these big enclosures for them like
in here put 47 of them and we are there
to provide protection for them and the
animals are in desperate need of that
protection no one knows exactly how many
chimps are still in the wild the best
guess is around 300,000 at the beginning
of the 20th century there were likely
millions
you